sono passati un anno e due mesi
crede e giusto siamo tornati sigla no
non abbiamo un silos ha però sto facendo
il professionale non ho una sigla io
dico che una sigla niente sigla verrà a
tutti i ragazzi vivete questo video sono
fa vj sono con il buon pietro dopo sei
anni no ragazzi allora che è successo è
da una vita che non facciamo minecraft
arcuri che è stata una deve essere di
più di successo in assoluto del canale
siccome l'ultimo bike park che aveva
fatto era il parkour spirale che questo
che stiamo guardando in questa
bellissima foto in hd
vabbè adesso esiste un nuovo minecraft
parkour che hanno fatto nel tempo mentre
noi ci trastullava mo che è questo in
realtà non renderizza avere tutto quanto
perché non renderizzare alla fine un tot
però questa qua è il marin un secondo mi
fa il fermo dove se no no non c'è tvp
questa come sfondo
sei un pezzetto
tra l'altro mi sa che è anche comparso
il titolo iniziato con tradimento va beh
questa è nuova ai caf harcourt che a
quanto pare si preannuncia veramente
figo ma scusa ma tu non puoi andare
direttamente a livello lì a sinistra
abbiamo facciamo le cose fatte bene chi
ha giustiziato zeus è chiaramente si
ottiene quando va bene ma se avrà fatto
molto meglio ragazzi siamo contentissimi
tre almeno io sono potete vincere st
nuova serie da una vita non lo facevamo
ci sei
ma io non mi ricordo manco più tasti
però va beh
let's go o il primo io non so quante
puntate faremo per finirlo soprattutto
con tel un drop ma sei sicuro che mi ami
ha detto pietro che pi difficile
dell'altro è sicuro
siccome faccio avere questa cosa perché
ho visto un po di cose di questo modo
hai visto delle robe
bene allora niente sono cascato rifaccio
e poi la cosa brutta è che c'è se cadi e
caduto di foche 68 tutto il che si
andavano a tutto il livello però è
stranamente tipo signor h di qua va in
acqua ripartì da zero
ah beh sì certo e poi al primo livello
cedere uno slam dove e dove vuoi andare
loro io sto facendo il giro sbagliato
aveva aspettato e non mi ricordo più
come ci sei mancato loro tantissimo sei
veramente un pezzente perché abbiamo
tenuto il pvp on ragazzi vi prego
vediamo il quindi io mi mancava tagliate
anche le era mancato arresto ieri ho
fatto
sì ci credo e non ti ho ripreso quindi
non vale ci ho creduto c'era tantissimo
grazie ciao
bellissimo a quanto pare anche questo è
passato più di un anno dall'ultima
minecraft non ci può far male ma non ve
lo so non facciamoci l'aiuto dovete
votare non è sbloccato devi venire qua a
un certo non facciamoci domanda non può
essere passato così tanto tempo
devi rifarti tutto io ti ha fatto
ripartire dove dal limite dall'inizio no
dopo un tot di crearvi check point
notizia quanto matericamente quando fai
il livello ai check point prima di
definire il livello non è che poi ok
allora vieni fin qua tante donne
occhiata pieni 40 dietro già difficile
ha poi quelli per le due c'è scritto
adesso a destro
adesso ha descritto livello 2 ogni volta
che aumentiamo al livello quindi ci si
può check point per forza però
attenzione che quaino italy dove bisogna
andare perché non c'è io siccome da
piramide immagina che devo andare sempre
più in alto tu no non nei giorni scorsi
riguardo però no pro tu vai tu ma io
sento molto due volte questo episodio va
bene non andiamo indietro si sia e
spadoni propria inizio del livello viene
qua e credo che bisognava wright sulla è
per forza se mentre la rosa
iverson entrata poi nascosto effetto
figo e molto figo e poi qua sopra
immagino e poi guardi fuori labor della
mescola effetto più caldo ma invece no
perfetto siamo bravissimi 96 cascato no
va bene io contiamo bravissimi bob carr
di vendola la finestra amico aspettami
aspettami così ste robe così che trip
vieni e non credo che no other way
c'è un'altra parte di sé venuto marche
what c'è un'altra scuola supporto esatto
malanova che figata veramente voi
casalinga si sia molto più bella delle
altre ti prego non datemi ricevuto
rivisto dall'iniziale livello tattico
ok non accada qui sotto nel trasporto si
discute ma si va benissimo ma di selena
tono no ma figurati non lo tocco da una
maglia nike hogan è passato un anno o
ancora qui sono morto non lo so perché
ok
mammamia vuota player livello 4 ma vieni
vieni vieni cosa stai dicendo
fermo secondo sale d'aspetto galli sly
esatto tra intatti bravissimo guarda lo
sborone arriva lui per farti vedere
quanto in realtà è facile ormai si
chiama karma questo e parma volevo fare
il trick shot deciso riuscito vabbè ma
non ci riuscirà momenti di scambio e di
dio ti aspetto ora ecco lo sapeva
benissimo
niente è bloccato il livello 3 è carica
ragazzi comunque colpisce io dico sempre
col pescina volessimo solai è veramente
fortissimo il cardinale
non ci ho pensato di aver seguito rai ma
adesso non faccio chiudono faccio da
schifoso vieni qua ciao ma è che non c'è
la c'è l'acqua c'è l'acqua non c'è la
lava e am di qua no no no no spegne
aia e non tornassi 19 spegne e proventi
spenti sono viola sul monitor che ne so
io da the comic and drought bene non è
possibile ma scarso arrivata la yo yo ma
per me non so perché sono di fatto
bravissimo hai visto pietro ma non sono
proprio bravo ma io a bordo che belle
queste cose della vita a una patata ce
l'ha fatta
occhio primo che male che male perché
cosa diavolo e ce l'ho fatta
come funzionano non ho capito ed
evidenti di poter trasportare su un
punto ma muovere no aiuto è
difficilissimo lo hanno reso ancor più
un problema sulle sei qui sotto ed è lo
slime e quindi è qui che che ne so so
bloccato aspetta no va bene comunque
allora siamo già arrivati alla parte
difficile nei casinò
ciao amico dove sei mi piace la lav
no non è vero io vedo rob è scusato
difficile sta parte veramente un casino
comunque sappia st parte sul serio
difficile perché ci provo ci riprovo è
tanto bello quanto difficile madonna
veramente difficile sta parte giuro
fetta questa parte un casino e questo
l'ha fatto difficile aspetta e siccome
fa ecco qua come fai
spiegami ciò è fatta devi correre dalla
parte dalla parte interna bravissimo
corri corri salta dai amico dai amico
dai amico forza il pitcher ho visto
ravissimo sic e dovi smascherato bravo
adesso sono veramente un fonico non lo
so se i ragazzi non ottimale sia un olio
e se voglio riparto da zero
quindi ti konsiglio di stare molto
all'occhio soprattutto mentre salto
mentre celava addosso che male quando e
che va via la lava basta spegne www.eu
funzionante durante questo facciamo qua
ok ok perfetto finale finisce tutto lì
patria ma non ci credo
era ancora era un troll c'era una
crollata no no la lazio ha visualizzato
bellissima ovviamente il giovanissimo
era era una tonnellata non avrei mai
detto
magari arrivo centro ma sai che non me
la sarei mai aspettata neanch'io perché
le studiata be nice
enova difficile non ci pensi a queste
cavolate porca vacca e come fai scusa
ok
guarda che roba se sbagli questo riporta
in essi
io ci credo
ci credo ancora sono bravissimo
ti prego per favore ok era molto più
panico pinarello 5 fatto è fatto sì che
l'udc e c'è di qua si è fatta no dammi
la mano agli ultimi e un pezzo di me va
bene amici prossimo l'importante è che
non perdiamo per ci sei
l'importante è che non non cadiamo nella
lava e non torniamo indietro il problema
è uno solo guarda io penso mi desse
livello se invece non siamo ancora al 5
quindi se moriamo con i fatti il salto
quelli slime o morire non morire e basta
tu non morire vai avanti non morire così
è utopistico come cosa e utopistica e
turistica come me lo diceva pietro bravo
porta acqua devi fare sesso con isla in
forza addirittura vieni e idee e belli e
bellissimo sto livello te lo giuro io
odio sullo store di livello
a me piace un sacco perfetto visto
questo affetto per percorrere facile ok
varese importante che non cadere
allora li sai che con un saluto viola io
mi sono buttato ma che sei scemo no no e
no ma no come riempirla veramente ma non
glielo aifo monori faccio più ma andiamo
avanti
dici di sì sì io faccio il test
attenzione che se cadi ti ti ti fulmina
zeus very good livello 6
sa io lessi picchiarti abbiamo paura o
in casa o c'è una cappa siamo riposarsi
un attimo chiamo davvero tra l'altro c'è
parkour anche qua dentro
no dai è di correre di qua dentro
se si va a vedere cosa c'era più fuori è
difficile però è molto più difficile
nell'altro
molto birrifici sì sì sì no no ma non so
se mi trai a caso bravissimo schifoso
no siamo dei dei secoli si sentano di
tutti e due
tutto da rifare quindi grazie a dio
siamo e quali orari fatto apposta
ci proverà ancora nel pezzo della lava
di prima ora che moriamo davvero ma novo
scherzando la mia mi uccido
ma questi non puoi aprirli toffolo
colombo cominciò ad arrabbiarmi su di
lei
ok nava un amo 9 che sono ancora nel
libro no già fatta aspetta mamma mia
quota player vieni vieni ok ragazzi si
aspetta che mi sto concentrando qua devi
passare vai avanti
bravo non così colleghi e devi andare
avanti
ok devi devi farti capire al carrello
perché i carrelli ti esplodono in faccia
la cosa che fa male fa male di qua penso
che si debba fare invece così che figata
suo livello molto bene player miv aver
anteprima pochissimi anche diverse non
capisco perché è il tuo computer non
regge minecraft aspetta vado giù ok
molto difficile questa parte però ci sto
riuscendo
non male sono sono bravissimo non so
come mai mi è rimasta la skill dal dagli
scorsi parkour western force quale
ficile perché disse lodi che è un
piacere
ce l'ho fatta ho fatto livello ma come
te lo giuro e la parola viene qua invece
penso sia ok varie realtà di tesori sono
miley e tenta livello scendi scendi
perfetto
ok lascio un bottone questo forse
l'affare in due
ora dovete fin dopo il passaggio segreto
è bellissimo vieni vieni sei finito sono
qua ok allora va presa da compenso il
ministro è lo so ok questo le cose più
piccole a farci a crearci problemi
a quest'ora è già finito questo no io mi
rifiuto ma non è possibile ma che non è
questo il colpo di fornet soldi come
corpo agli ex forse due domande me le
farei ma c'e la lettera che non l'avevo
vista lago ecco le dico una sega
di fatto spiega medica stata tanta da
noah d'ore l'ora che è successo un
casino qui di saltare sui blocchi
singoli vai vai vai ci ho creduto
tantissimo
adesso slime lo slancio ma tu centrato
tantissimo vieni vieni vieni raisi non
l'hai fatto
no quindi ragazzi minecraft alcun
finisce qua continuano nel prossimo
visione del buon pietro come al solito
ragazzi sia video è piaciuto condividere
con tutti i vostri amici lasciato molte
miglia cercava regionali esistiti se non
sarà così
iscrivetevi e noi come sempre ci vediamo
da ragazzi
[Musica]